bonsoir merci d'être en direct avec nous
sur arte france est ce que vous nous
confirmer que plusieurs départements de
votre région seront donc
concernés par l'avancement de deux
heures à 18 heures donc ne se couvrent
saut et bien écoutez manifestement vous
le confirmer je ne suis pas dans le
secret des dieux mais comme on nous
l'annoncent depuis depuis quelques
heures manifestement nous allons être
dans les bouches du rhône puisque c'est
le département où j'habite ou jeudi où
je suis élue aussi municipal et et bien
nous allons être confiné à partir de 18h
avec un conte rocheuses donc est ce que
c'est la série suivante est ce que ce
serait là la solution si c'était
confirmé en pour l'instant ce sont des
rumeurs
vous ne savez donc que visiblement pas
plus que nous pour l'instant
est ce que ce serait la solution pour
contenir la propagation du cosy de 19
écoutez contenir peut-être mais
apparemment au jour d'aujourd'hui est
bien les cas sont toujours sont toujours
assez important et donc ça n'a pas l'air
d'avoir des effets des décès de flagrant
puisque de deux coureurs à 20h en place
de cours à 18 heures les faits en fait
surtout que ça lalalalala causé là par
là ce que cela ce que cela démontre
surtout et bien c'est l'incompétence du
gouvernement
finalement et l'errance du gouvernement
face à cette crise sanitaire
une errance qui se puisse continue qui
se perpétue bien depuis le début de la
crise de la copie de luzenac de tous
bords les élus font aujourd'hui seront
communs dans votre région contre cette
mesure dans tous les cas moi aujourd'hui
je suis dans je suis allé je suis
exceptionnellement dans les alpes à
barcelonnette et je suis allez donc voir
un petit peu à la rencontre aussi des
habitants m'ont fait c'est dans l'est en
provence alpes côte d'azur je suis allé
à la rencontre des professionnels du
tourisme du ski des remontées mécaniques
ont là aussi on a une fermeture des
remontées mécaniques alors que d'un
autre côté vous avez des et supermarchés
partout dans toute la france qui sont
ouverts où il n'y a aucune distanciation
social respecter donc vous avez une
situation qui est complètement aberrante
complètement délirante d'un côté des
stations de sports d'hiver avec la
montagne de l'air pur et cetera où vous
avez donc des gens qui sont obligés
contraint pas d'avoir une saison qui
complètement complètement terminée et
puis vous avez donc ces saisies qui a
marché ou ses grands magasins qui par
exemple à marseille à marseille qu'on
peut le constater on rien aucune règle
sanitaire réelle n'est respectée donc
y'a quand même un paradoxe il y a une
cohérence absolue des mesures sanitaires
et du gouvernement seront soit soit il
ya des mesures sanitaires réels pour
tout le monde
soit et bien on arrête on les
restaurants ou les remontées mécaniques
ont fait vivre l'économie parce que de
toute façon si vous voulez ya quelque
chose qui est à deux vitesses
voilà on a l'impression que d'un côté on
veut favoriser les grands groupes est
clair et que les petits commerçants les
restaurateurs et les gens qui se battent
pour le tourisme et pour au bal à laver
tous les jours et bien eux sont punis
finir cette exhortation aujourd'hui
entre les élus et l'état
manifestement il n'y en a pas puisque si
l'état l'état redescendu de son olympe
si monsieur castex monsieur macron
monsieur vers en redescendre et de l'or
olympique qui vraiment très très très
éloignée de la réalité du terrain les
français
et encore une fois je parle de ma région
mais ça se place donc tous les
départements dans beaucoup de
départements en tout cas et dans mon
petit la france et bien je crois qu'il
verrait enfin réellement ce qu'est la
situation économique qui est dramatique
qu'on parlait au jeu j'ai parlé
aujourd'hui à un responsable de deux
hommes d'une
l'une de location de skis à praloup et
bien qu'ils me qui me confiait en fait
tu es trop à l'agonie à la comprenne
bien
à quoi est dû ce retard dans l'annoncé
des départements qui seront concernés
par l'avancement du couvre-feu
s'il n'y a pas des changes pourquoi
est-ce que la bourse n'a t'elle pas été
fait bien plus rapidement par les
préfectures concernées
et après l'annoncé après tout simplement
j'imagine jeu j'en suis convaincu parce
que encore une fois monsieur véran
monsieur k sexe ne savent pas où ils
vont ils font des annonces en fonction
de tête
bon alors il faut quand même imaginer
que de plus en plus de tests aujourd'hui
qui sont fait ça il faut pas me
constatés donc évidemment forcément de
plus en plus de 15 et puis un
gouvernement qui ne ne sait pas gérer
depuis le départ donc au finalement
c'est un petit au petit bonheur la
chance
alors on prend sur des critères qu'on a
ce sont pas des critères si l'on voulait
à un moment donné il va falloir nous
dire clairement quels sont les critères
qui sont pris pour réellement qu'elles
sont quel est l'impact de ces critères
qu'elle abat scientifique de tes
critères qui sont pris pour imposé des
couvre-feux à 20 heures à 18 heures dans
les départements quel est le nombre le
stock exact de vaccins quelqu'un comme
ça a été plus le même coup pour les
masquer on est dans l'errance encore une
fois on est dans l'errance on est dans
un monde a l'impression que ce
gouvernement avance à l'aveuglette et ça
c'est très grave parce qu'il ne donne
aucune perspective aux français ils ne
donnent ils ne donnent pas l'impression
déjà de ne pas une impression de sérieux
il ne donne aucune perspective aux
français alors que normalement il
devrait y avoir il doit y avoir très
certainement des chiffres beaucoup plus
clair un tout dernier mot assez
rapidement si vous le voulez bien un mot
sur la situation épidémique dans votre
région
il a écouté qu'est-ce que vous voulez
que
dans une situation épidémique dans la
région moi je suis pas scientifique
encore une fois je fais de la politique
je ne connais pas quel est l'état de la
situation épidémique
moi ce que je vois dans ma région c'est
qu'il ya des professionnels des
restaurateurs des commerçants des
cafetiers des tas de gens qu'on voyait
dans des villages bd des cafés des
petites barres des choses fermé et que
vous y derrière que des familles
entières qui vont être touchés forcément
économiquement et forcément à terme par
le chômage des faillites
et bien moi c'est ça surtout qu'ils me
kim kim qui m'importe
et je me dis qu'elle réponde va donner
le gouvernement à ces gens qui va
falloir qu'il ordonnerait qui leur donne
une réponse économique
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
réagir sur notre antenne et les
hollandaises je rappelle que vous êtes
conseillère régionale du rassemblement
national en région paca